with writing
my advice that no one ever takes
is take as long as you can to write the
key is really yeah this is take your
time give yourself the time so i test my
films all the time with audiences and i
get feedback and say what do you think
of this how were you bored here we you
know we overstimulated here was it too
funny here you know it wasn't too sad
here it's really like just sort of
massaging the audience through the story
and like figuring it out yeah okay
where do you want to go now okay we'll
go over here and i'll show you this you
can't say
oh well they didn't get it
if there's a filmmaker you can't you
don't have the right
so i'm going to write a script
that's really good and i'm going to let
that be the pitch so i wrote the
screenplay and i just sent that around
i'm not going to come and talk to you
about it you just read the script and if
you like it then we can talk
the really cool thing about about making
film is there's
there's still an honest transaction
between the artist and the audience
uh in the gallery world uh it's pretty
much constructed of [ __ ] someone
comes in off the street and is told
why a piece of art is good
and that
sucks
i like film because
an audience is paying
quite a lot of money these days for the
right
to judge your work and you can't say
oh well they didn't get it
there's a filmmaker you can't you don't
have the right the thing about this is
though it you you wrote a script that is
uh it's just everyone's politically
correct nowadays and i commend you for
this material taking on this material
and fox searchlight for making it uh was
it tough to get the green light on this
thing there was no real pitching process
for this so i didn't go to studios and
sort of say hey this is my idea for a
film it's about this kid and growing up
in world war two it was um i realized
really early on that it's a very hard
film to pitch and i'm coming from new
zealand we're terrible at pitching so i
didn't really bother and
after talking to my friends and saying
they said what are you up to now and
what are you writing well i'm doing this
thing it's about this kid in world war
ii and they were
i'm not interested and so that kind of
that made me realize oh no one really
wants to hear a pitch like this so i'm
going to write a script that's that's
really good and i'm going to let that be
the pitch so i wrote the screenplay and
i just sent that around i said i'm not
going to come talk to you about it you
just read the script and if you like it
then we can talk here's the thing 90
of all ideas are [ __ ]
and 90 of all art is terrible
90 percent of all movies are pretty bad
and i think if you kind of take that
ratio into account it allows you to
relax a lot more you know you don't have
to worry about making something good all
the time
when i'm writing i know that a lot of it
is
should never see the light of day i find
that
taking the risks is
you reap bigger rewards from that and if
i feel like i'm playing it safe or i'm
too complacent a bit too comfortable
doing something then i feel like my work
suffers and it's happened a couple of
times just so i'm like
sort of not even in film but like in
just in general life just feeling like
the easy way
ultimately becomes the hard way because
you're not paying a price which is
you know you
you basically just make mediocre work
so i find like kind of
you know you kind of force yourself to
walk into the fire a bit and um
and
and you're on your toes and you're you
know you're kind of just you're just
trying to survive constantly
then you come up with really great new
ideas and you know you've come up with
more inventive solutions to the problems
right what would be a cool end what
would be a cool scene
this would be kind of fun and if i
collect enough of those little things
then i think maybe is there some sort of
shape to this i don't think anyone and
i'd be worried if someone actually did
do this i don't think anyone actually
says i'm going to make a movie where the
theme is about
if you're thinking like that then
there's something wrong with you no one
thinks with theme first theme is
something that comes later once you've
finished the film
and then some nerdy film student goes i
think the thing is about loyalty and
then you go yeah totally i was totally
thinking about loyalty when i made this
um
so the process is also faking it
faking it till you make it and then this
particular film there wasn't any
particular one thing that i found really
hard it was more
the tonal balance just trying to get
that right so i test my films all the
time with audiences and i'd say get
feedback and say what do you think of
this
were you bored here were you know we
overstimulated here was it too funny
here you know was it too sad here and
then just finding your balance and go
okay well now
let's take the audience
you know they've been they've yeah
they've had the deep meaningful moments
you know they've been it's been
emotional now we can slowly pick them up
with some lightness and get into a few
jokes here and then kind of ease them
back into this bit here and then and
it's really like just sort of
massaging the audience through the story
and like figuring out asking them are
you okay
where do you want to go now okay well
let's go over here and i'll just go and
show you this
so that's
essentially how i try and make a maybe
jermaine and i i think started writing
this in around 2004
maybe over like the next sort of six
years or so we just like every
couple of weeks a year we would just
like get back into it and just reopen up
the script jermaine and either way that
we work we end we would end up like
doing maybe a page a year and then we
ended up with 150 pages so it took 150
years to write the script with writing
my advice that no one ever takes
is take as long as you can to write i
will write and then i will take i'll put
the script away and i won't look at it
for
maybe six months maybe a year sometimes
i
would take two years away from the
script hunt for the older people i wrote
the first draft in maybe 2004
and
uh we shot that in 2015.
you do the math
that's just the process
and then that time i made three other
features so you know this
you're kind of like drifting around all
your different projects but um yeah
that's
the key is really yeah this is take your
time give yourself the time the thing
about like a lot of studio films in
hollywood films especially is
when you hear a joke in these films
you get the feeling that the joke was
written about a year before they shot it
you know it's like it's been in the
script for a long time and someone you
know a couple of people in the boardroom
like oh and then he's going to say
uh you know it's like oh it's going to
be amazing when we shoot there in a year
um how we did it on thor was
our script really was a suggestion and
um you know and so all the jokes were
kind of like
maybe and we went we got on set and
we basically explored what more we could
do and and so i think the humor is a
very different style of humor for
definitely for superhero movies the
formula is um make them more human
um the thing with thor and i think with
a lot of a lot of superheroes at least
is
the weirdos you know they're like
they're um
it's very hard to relate to them because
i had to get to figure out the um
the kind of human traits that they
possess especially with thor because
there's an alien and you know and he's
like a rich kid he lives in a palace and
you know it's very hard to kind of
understand where he's coming from
so with with him the key really was to
um
was to tap into chris's strengths which
uh you know the fact that he's funny and
charming and
um and you know
he's kind of
friend who you you would want to go on
an adventure with yeah but also i think
that they're very relatable um you know
they're going to have human characters
they have to they have to they have to
um you know thor is um
i mean essentially he's a rich kid from
outer space and you know he's uh he just
wants to be loved and you know he wants
to be like we're all riches who want to
be loved um and the hulk is uh you know
it's kind of like this bipolar disorder
you know he can't control and uh you
know
i love the you know that the theme of of
hulk you know it's just an age-old idea
of wrestling these two
beings within you and i mean there is
really something if we look at every
character they probably dress
ridiculously but um you know there is
something related is there is there
similarities though i mean it's i'm kind
of painting like it's two completely
different worlds like making more of an
indie film they are very similar like
what and the way that you get into these
the way that i could kind of you know
make myself feel like i had something to
offer and and that um i guess
somehow that there was an in for me
creatively was to think of this thing
like an independent film so you know
really when you look at the story it's
just about a guy trying to get home
because there's a burglar in his house
and he's trying to get home you know
across across the
just happens to be across the university
he's trying to he's trying to travel but
um you know this is really like after
hours um set in space you know he's like
accompanied by his annoying brother and
a drunk chick and this bipolar guy who's
prone to temper tantrums and if you
think about it like that just the
simplicity of the story
that's my in that's the way that i can
figure out how to make these characters
more relatable to the audience and you
know humanity congratulations the film
is bigger funnier
taiki you wrote it how do you
even start writing a marvel movie like
do you have to be across all the
things that are happening in the other
movies
what do i do i try and ignore that
so um it's too i'm too lazy too lazy
people
i know eventually you'll probably get to
a star wars um question yeah i'm too
lazy to have watched everything and read
everything i don't know what happened to
this stuff i'll just try and do my own
thing with marvel the same thing i
wanted to do
i want to do something that
challenged thor that made sense in a new
way thor going through a midlife crisis
trying to find himself trying to find
his purpose
and if i get out of my lane then it's
marvel's job to kind of keep me in check
and say you can't do that because that
character needs to be in this other
movie so i think failure is a brilliant
thing it teaches you a lot of stuff and
um and all you know and you you end up
coming up with better ideas often when
you when you fail at things um
and you know i think what's really great
also is
learning to
embrace
bad experiences bad creative experiences
and you know watch bad movies you know
read bad books and because all of that
stuff sometimes it teaches you what not
to do and so you know for me one bad
experience i had was i played a stripper
on a tv show once um
and uh you know i remember sitting
around in the green room in my g-string
thinking why am i doing this
just helping someone else to realize
their dream and so what i ended up doing
was i started writing my own
scripts and stuff in the screen in my
g-string and then
a few months later i made a short film
and then that went on to uh go to the
oscars about a year later um
but i lost so obviously that was a
complete waste of time but um
you know it's
it was me at the oscars asleep i always
prefer to work with my friends um on
shadows it was jermaine and i we
surrounded ourselves with all of our
other friends you know including stu
who
i went to high school with and jackie i
went to high school with i've known them
since i was about 12 or 13. yes she was
a flatmate of mine
for years it's actually the best way of
working like because you can give each
other [ __ ] you can like you know pick on
each other and it's more like working
with your family you don't have to beat
around the bush with stuff you can just
be honest and yeah they're the people i
trust the most when um asking for
feedback or you know when i if i've got
a criticism i know that it's coming from
a place of love or that you know they
actually are concerned about something
in a scene or something so which is
often yeah if you don't know someone
you're a bit wary when you go from
having the first germ of an idea for
something to writing your first draft do
you
do you spend a lot of time sort of
really digging into and thinking you
really really know your characters
inside out before you start that first
draft and do you outline and do a
treatment and know every scene or do you
just kind of crack on with your first
draft and then rewrite rewrite rewrite
yeah i i do the um
lots of notes and beats and like try and
figure out the story before typing
because i've found that typing is
really horrible
um and just it just hurts
um
your body
and your mind to sit in front of a blank
screen and now what's next i like to
just have the whole plan out in front of
me and know and but basically how i rise
i'll start with
the beginning and the end
i just want to really like visually or
like just something that i think it's
like this would be a cool way to end a
movie and this would be a cool last
image for an audience to see this would
be a cool first image and this will be a
cool way to open the film and then i'll
start and then i'll put in some scenes
throughout i think this would be a great
scene and then eventually when i've got
enough of these scenes or sequences then
lazily just glue them all together with
some sort of connecting scenes
but that's it really that's sort of what
i that's my style and when i know what
it is then i can write really fast but
if i'm just sitting there with like
if you would say i wrote a story about
you know uh soothsayer on a mission to
find some
um
some herbs
in the fantasy land and then i just had
to look at a blank page i would not i'd
be there for a year without typing
anything unless i
sat down and like wrote out and figured
it all out i think
your
indigeneity
or indigenousness or ingeniousness
or ingenuity
um informs everything you do because
it's just who you are you know it's um
i wouldn't i'm i'm never thinking about
it in the moment
because it's just why would you
who wants to be thinking like that all
day long how can i make this more
indigenous how am i going to like dress
more indigenous how am i you know you
just never think about
you know am i eating indigenous eggs um
it's just it's too exhausting having to
think like that so but having it be part
of your
genetic makeup and and who you are
yeah it informs everything and
especially and also i think your
upbringing is a big part of that
i think you know you get a white
completely white person and make them
grow up in an indigenous community
community and they'll think the same way
as an indigenous person you know if they
had the exact same experiences and stuff
so a lot of it i think is actually
upbringing and background
which yeah also informs a lot of what i
do but i actually that's the way i
prefer to write
and this is
my little here's my little trick that
none of you will want to do
i will write a draft and then i'll put
it away for a year or so and then
uh or even two years or even three years
and then i'll come back to it and i'll
read it and i go who wrote this [ __ ]
and then i will read it like maybe two
or three times and then i will
throw that away and then rewrite it from
page one based on the memory of how of
what i read
and then my 120 page script will
suddenly be 80 pages
and it'll just be the bare bones and
just like the
the
yeah the important parts or the members
of the things like
remember from reading the script and so
i think there's like that's like quite a
good filter
system and then when you have like this
very sort of bare bones short version of
your story then you can add back in some
tonal stuff and some you know more jokes
and [ __ ] and stuff like that but yeah so
that takes a long way longer than anyone
wants to do how do you inject humor into
those scenes because in this in this
film you actually do that a fair number
of times in the midst of a big action
sequence where most films wouldn't know
how to do it you know how to inject a
joke or a line i think of ruffalo you
know jumping out of the ship it's just a
wonderful moment
well most of the time when we're doing
the film whenever we approach something
like you know a big action sequence or
you know or even a scene
we would often ask ourselves and talk to
each other and say have we seen this
before does this feel like we've seen
that in 10 other movies if so let's do
the opposite and let's have you know
instead of
you know
mark jumping down and turning into the
hulk and landing on the bridge he has
this you know his big platform
um
so you're largely you do mostly comedy
that's like what you're drawn to that's
what you're yeah you voices
i'm so sorry
pigeon holds you uh but my question is
um
did you always know that was kind of
the what you wanted to write and do you
have any advice for people who
want to write like right now i'm writing
something that's like very
dramatic and tragic but i'm i feel like
oh just don't do it we don't need any
more depressing films
no when i wrote boy the first version of
boy was super depressing
and super sad and hunt for the world of
people the first version was like just
sad i was just like oh i'm going to be
like lucas medicine
i'm just going to make a really
depressing round
i realized i don't know how to do that
i'm not good at that and so i just
i decided to just
look at what i was good at which is you
know
you know
i'm a reprobate and uh you know i'm like
i don't and i'm
don't like rules and i don't
like
depressing films
like i just i decided i made a choice
i said to myself
do you really like depressing films and
i said back to myself in the husky voice
no
no
and you know i then jermaine said the
really important thing to me when we
were doing when we were shooting what we
do in the shadows there was a point
where we were like
um we're turning like a five minute idea
into a feature film this is what we'll
be doing and he goes dude the world
needs stupid [ __ ]
we need
we need the ridiculous because
you know who wants to go and say like he
wants to go and see a film
that reminds us about how terrible the
world is
we just like go on twitter and uh you
know let's just look at the news and
save ourselves two hours
you know so it's i think the world needs
we need an escape we need these things
to remind ourselves that we are stupid
creatures we are clumsy we're the
clumsiest of all animals
you know
nowhere in the animal kingdom we see an
animal that will like
smash their head like four times in a
row on like you know on something or
like you know trip over themselves
we are dumb as [ __ ]
so
we should embrace that
and so yeah so yeah yes there's room for
like you know beautiful
um human films maybe the dramatic but
i think that
you can also you know
it's like a you know it's like a little
um
you subvert that you know it's like it's
like it's just like the payload is like
the themes and like you know the
stuff that means something but if the
plane is like dressed like a clown
anyone's going oh cool
and then you drop that payload like
that's the way i think
that makes the film important because
every day you think people walk around
being depressed all day long and i mean
some some do yes but
you know it's you know no one walks
around like you know
in a dancer in the dark kind of like
situation you know you know it's like
well you know like breaking the waves
like this is a sad set
it's light and dark all day long you
know so i think that's why
why i like my films is because
it's like light and dark
and there's a mix and there's it's
you've got to find that balance but
that's and that's why i think
the way i try and do things is is
more human
more in touch with like how humans are
every day
if you come from a [ __ ] background and
poor community
you laugh all day first and foremost
don't don't listen to people's advice
and um i'd say really just like listen
to yourself and but you know it's
i i've i realized that
if you look at any artist you know it's
it's less about following them because
they probably didn't follow someone else
so they probably you know the great
artist doesn't really copy or try and um
and replicate someone else's career and
so i think that's that's an incentive to
really stick to your own guns and follow
your own vision and do your own thing
i just say look at art is the the thing
that really
inspired me to to try different things
and i only came to screenwriting and
filmmaking in my late twenties but
before that
if i would have come to london i spent
most of my time at the galleries like
the national and the tate and stuff and
i just yeah i mean i
i just love seeing
art in general it doesn't matter what it
is just having some sort of
window into someone else's mind or
someone else's creative process i think
it all helps to inspire you and to get
you motivated to do your own thing
i've come to realize that i do
i do know some stuff like
it's you never really
stop and think about how much you know
how much you might know because i don't
think many people
um
are that sort of self-centered i'm
pretty self-centered but not that
self-centered like you know
i'd only realized after they asked me to
do it that um i thought oh maybe
actually i do i've been doing this for
almost like 13 years or something now so
i've got to know something i developed
my style of of writing down all the
beats and all of the the different parts
of the the story before actually
typing
quite early on because i i realized
i didn't really know i didn't know how
to format scripts back when i started
off and when i first started
screenwriting
it was like on
microsoft word and so i'd seen scripts
from when i was an actor but i didn't
like and so i don't use the space bar to
go all the way into the middle of the
page i didn't know about tab that
started seeing the spacebar again all
the way there and then type the
character's name and then like press
enter space bar all the way there to
start doing the dialogue so they're
really wonky and so
so it took me a long time doing that
because
i
i mean i didn't know how to do that but
also i didn't really know what i was
writing like i knew kind of what the
characters were doing but i got stuck on
blank pages all the time so i started
just doing things by hand and writing
all my dialogue by hand
first and so that's with all my short
films i'd write everything
by hand and then when i knew
the structure i knew when it was good
then i would then i'd start typing it
out so my one question is i also like
like writing scripts that aren't like
the huge the usual script that's really
like
off the beat and also like as a bit of
humor not to the normal so how do you
like what advice would you give to pitch
something like that for two investors
and try and get him on board with
something that's not really
of
the norm
uh well
sadly i've never i mean i mean also i'm
happy about it but i've never had to
really do pitching or
try and like find finance that way like
we're very lucky in new zealand with the
film commission like if you go to them
and you have a project that they believe
in then that's sort of how we get our
stuff funded and so only outside of that
i've only worked with marvel and
in recently fox searchlight on my
world war ii film and
but
traditionally what i do and i because i
have a lot of friends who are writers
and they say things like oh i've got
this great idea it's about this and this
is it oh great so you should write that
and they go
i'm going to wait till i get some
funding
i thought you uh you i thought you were
a writer yeah yeah no no but i'm gonna
wait until yeah i'm gonna put put in my
petition then get some get some money
and then i can start writing
but
that's not how it works you just if you
want to write something you're
passionate about it just go write it
like
you just got to write it and so i've
never
traditionally i just wrote my scripts
until they were at a point where i
thought that they were ready to shoot
and then i went
for finance
i didn't go in and go i've got a
you know
one page synopsis and i want money so
that i can start like so my fingers will
work you know it's like
no i would just like do the work
right for a year and then go in and say
this is what i've worked on
i think this film's good you know and so
that's how i work you know i would do
the work first and then take it
you